the u.n charter was written with the
express purpose
of preventing a war like the one
president putin just started
the war has brought as u.s ambassador to
the united nations linda thomas
greenfield is helping lead the country's
many diplomatic efforts around the world
including our response to the russian
invasion of ukraine her post at the u.n
is a one-mile straight shot east of our
times square studio that's where i
recently met up with the ambassador for
a chat about foreign policy gun violence
and racial justice right in the room
where it happens
it has launched more missiles in the
past five months than in the prior two
years it name an issue with worldwide
implications we are deeply concerned and
it winds up here in this stately room on
manhattan's east side you're president
of the u.n security council i am for the
month of may what does that feel like
it feels like a great responsibility
leading the conversation on this
15-member council the agenda is adopted
is ambassador linda thomas greenfield a
35-year veteran of the foreign service
with posts in europe the middle east and
africa she was ambassador to liberia and
is known in these halls simply as
ltg
l t j
at the center of any given international
crisis the provisional agenda for this
meeting is maintenance of peace and
security of ukraine
the hottest conflict now on her plate is
raging in eastern europe where are we
with russia
four seats away
are we
in a stalemate a state of war we are not
in a state of war with uh with russia
here in the security council we're
engaging with them on what is happening
in ukraine but we're also engaging on
what's happening in syria we're engaging
on what's happening in yemen
and we have discussions
around this
table on all of those issues she is also
mobilizing the western alliance against
its aggression today we call on russia
to stop its unprovoked
unjustified
unconscionable war but diplomacy is hard
work especially when all five permanent
members have veto power against u.n
resolutions we certainly have countries
that are totally in accord with us
they're countries who are wavering and
then we have russia and china russia and
china i mean what do we call them at
this stage i call them a bromance
not to be light about this china has
decided it will
tie itself to russia's aggression
against ukraine which is out of
character for them for now the united
states government is aligned with
congress passing a bipartisan 40 billion
ukrainian aid package and if ukraine
falls then what
we're not going to sit back and allow
ukraine to fall
she left the state department in 2017
and returned to become a formal member
of president biden's cabinet as u.n
ambassador how often do you get to those
cabinet level meetings i attend every
cabinet meeting her journey here began
in the tiny segregated town of baker
louisiana she was protected by her
close-knit family but that said we had
crosses burnt by the klan in our
community every single weekend i was
bussed
for 30 minutes past baker high school to
go to the black high school so we could
see these schools and we knew they were
better equipped
but what they didn't have were the black
teachers that we had who wanted to make
sure
that they prepared us for success
in spite of racism
and so while it was difficult
i look back on it and realize that who i
am today is because i went through that
you are your ancestors wildest dreams
a message of hard-earned wisdom she's
taken on the college commencement
circuit from mississippi's hbcu tougaloo
college global challenges even those in
far away places are going to impact you
to predominantly white university of
wisconsin where she attended grad school
we have climate change we have migration
issues we have food insecurity mass
shootings war what was your message to
to young people in a way they could
understand
and connect well first and foremost
they can't sit on the sidelines i said
yesterday at columbia that we'd failed
them
because we'd not address these issues
they've been prepared for it and it's
their time to address it and matters of
domestic importance are also part of her
agenda we spoke to her just two days
after the grocery store massacre in
buffalo new york what do you think this
says to the folks who are leading other
nations
who are representing other nations you
know it's interesting so last night i
started getting text messages on
the security council whatsapp
group
expressing condolences
to me and to the united states for
what happened i think they understand
that we do have a crisis in the united
states that racism exists i've never
denied it i've acknowledged it here in
new york at the united nations
that we have an issue
still with racism we must face it down
every time
what were you hoping
to connect
to your to your colleagues you know my
message is we're not perfect
we are not a perfect democracy
but we can acknowledge our weaknesses
and that's a strength to be able to
acknowledge that you have an issue and
work to address it so let's work to
address those issues and make our
countries more
human rights friendly
and more racially
integrated issues she believes can only
be solved in this space it is still the
one place
where 193
countries
all of these flags
where we can come together and find
commonality
discuss our differences and find
solutions it is the only place that we
can do that
and one of the surprising things out of
this interview was finding out that the
human security council has a whatsapp
group chat uh really interesting woman
because
she's she's definitive about talking to
young people because her exposure to the
foreign service came in baker louisiana
when someone from the state department
came to speak and it just opened up her
world to this possibility i love what
she said to the kids at the graduation
you're your ancestors while i'll be
right right well also keeping in mind
that more work needs to be done
absolutely and the time is now